Hey Thoughty2 here.
Phobophobia is an intense fear of developing
a phobia.
When you are born you only have two fears,
a fear of falling and loud noises.
These are natural survival mechanisms built
into our DNA and passed down through the generations.
Every other fear you face, you have learnt
throughout your life.
Dikephobia is a fear of justice and Eleutherophobia
is a fear of freedom.
You'll have to stay clear of the Netherlands
if you have Dutchphobia, a fear of the Dutch.
Euphobia is a fear of hearing good news, but
don't tell them there's a cure.
Some phobias can be unexplainably bizarre,
such as Levophobia which is a fear of things
to the left of your body.
Lutraphobia is a fear of otters.
Did you know that otters hold hands whilst
sleeping so they don't drift away from each.
How can something so otterly adorable be scary.a
Pentheraphobia is a fear of your mother-in-law.
One New Scientist reader discovered a telephone
helpline dedicated to helping those with a
variety of ailments, one of these was Telephonophobia,
a fear of telephones.
Xanthophobia is the fear of the colour yellow.
Xanthophobics can be afraid of the sun, daffodils,
yellow paint, and many other yellow objects.
In some aggressive cases of Xanthophobia,
sufferers are even afraid of the word "yellow".
Somniphobia is a fear of falling asleep.
Somniphobes fear falling asleep because they
associate it with dying.
It can also be related to a feeling of lack
of control or from suffering repeated nightmares.
Some Somniphobes are simply scared of losing
time whilst sleeping.
Think that's difficult to live with?
It's not as bad as Phronemophobia.
Phronemophobia is a fear of thinking.
Nomophobia is the fear of being without mobile
phone coverage.
It may sound ridiculous but it has been well
observed by researchers and is actually one
of the biggest phobias.
A survey in the UK revealed that 54% of Britons
suffer from Nomophobia.
Suffers fear losing signal, running out of
battery or simply losing sight of their phone.
Papaphobia is a rare fear of the Pope or Papacy.
It is closely related to Hierophobia, a fear
of holy individuals or sacred objects.
It is usually related to a traumatic experience
associated with the Pope.
Pogonophobia is a strong fear of beards.
The term has been used since the 1850s.
British journalist Jeremy Paxman recently
accused the BBC of suffering from Pogonophobia
after he was criticised for sporting a beard
whilst presenting Newsnight.
Similarly, Peladophobia is a fear of bald
people.
But the cruelest phobia of all is Hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia.
This ironically named phobia is the fear of
long words.
Now that's just mean.
Suffers of Hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia
are scared of the name of their own phobia.
And finally Anatidaephobia is the fear that
wherever you are, whatever you're doing, there
is a duck watching you.
Unfortunately the fear isn't real, it was
made up by Gary Larson.
But that hasn't stopped many people from believing
there are actual sufferers of Anatidaephobia.